i mean you said your purpose is to bring
people together through music
i mean what does it mean for you to
bring joy to people at a time like this
well i feel lucky for sure to be able to
do this for a living i think
that art art in general all art but i'm
fond of music but
but all art finds a way
in the toughest times to raise its hand
and let's say that i'm here for you
say that i'll be your i'll be your soft
place to land
i'll be your up here the pillow you cry
on
i'll be your catharsis i'll be all those
things for you
and it's it's funny how music always
seems to do that i mean all
are but music in particular always finds
a way to
and it's tough as an artist and i think
that this album feels like to me that
to be able to create
an escapism on one hand but also be able
to put your finger on the pulse
of things that are going on and things
that are bothering people and
and things that are going on in real
life in an intimate way
in people's lives is is a tough thing to
do and i think
we found the songs and the music and
sonically
and the story that we use all those
things together
here on earth is a very powerful title
and it made me think about what is
happening right now how would you
describe
2020 wow the worst year ever
the song right there let me know but
there's been a lot of great things
that's happened
in my family you know my daughter
graduated from stanford in 2020 my
youngest daughter from high school in
2020
so it's good stuff but it's stuff that
they're missing out on on some of the
great
moments in life that that that those
accomplishments
pretend you know and so we tried to make
it as well
as good as we can but we've also had
great moments as a family because we're
forced to you know you're forced to
quarantine you're forced to be together
we the last four weeks
you know i have i've had my daughter
from from
l.a who's an actress my oldest daughter
gracie
she was here and had a friend of hers
here and
and my daughter maggie from from palo
alto brought her boyfriend
and we had extra dogs and my wife
and everybody was tested and so we
quarantined up on the hill and
and we made these great dinners every
night and
the kids set table outs set tables
outside that looked like something out
of a movie
uh games we watched movies
only one or two fights so it was it was
had great
robust you know political and social
conversations yeah musical conversations
at night so it was it was
i'll look back at this last four weeks
just being one of the greatest
periods of time i got to spend with my
family
that's the silver lining right you were
supposed to be on this massive tour the
summer tour
did you pick up a new new hobbies have
you learned
baking have you done something different
no new hobbies i mean i'm
i'm pretty i'm pretty my my uh download
capacity is pretty full
right now hobbies but i haven't even got
to do much of the ones i do have
um but but i've read a lot more than
usual
i mean i'm a big reader anyway so i i
try to read quite a bit and try to just
you know you always try to discover in
times of madness like this you try to
discover things that you can learn and
things that
that you can come out of this with a
better perspective on
and i called mama cue to the tears man i
at this video the
song i call my mom right after i'm a mom
and i always like to get the dad's
perspective when you get married
your wife becomes this mom to your
daughter your three daughters
what is that journey for you to watch
that happen
it's incredible i mean you know to see
the bond that they have and the
relationship that they have
i mean i grew up with my mom and two
sisters so with that much of a dad
around so
so i used to that sort of connection and
i don't know much about a father-son
connection so
mostly my my my knowledge comes from
a mother son or a mother-daughter
connection
um but i tell you my my daughters have
grown up to be
strong independent um outspoken
they don't take any from anybody
really good solid girls and and they're
good friends to their friends and and
their
their good daughters to their parents
and and i just thank god every day that
they had their mom as a role model
well yeah i have two daughters too and
you know what i'm learning more from
them than i've ever have
and especially in a time like this what
have they taught you or at least
is there one of them that's more similar
to you
well they all have different traits that
are similar i don't know that there's
one that's more similar they
it's funny how they they really equaled
out
faith in our both or both of our traits
on
the hard-headedness they got a double
dose of the head
so they all fall pretty hard-headed
because their mom and dad both are
pretty hard-headed so
so when we argue with them and we wonder
why they're we ask them
how come you're so hard-headed they just
look at us and laugh but
but um i don't know which one's the most
like us but um
i tell you they they um they are their
own people
but they they certainly they certainly
think and they think deep and they think
about how to make the world a better
place and
and that's never far from their mind and
that's something that's awesome to see
yeah they think so differently from our
generation it's so unique and so fun to
watch
yeah i'm very excited about and i'm glad
that my daughters are a part of
this generation we had this conversation
the other night now i know this is
a tough time and it's a hard time you
know i might my
my daughter graduating in from stanford
not having a graduation my daughter
graduated from high school not having a
graduation or college
here and all those things and i know
this is tough times but
you're not going through it alone in
fact you're going through it with more
support than
probably you would have had any of this
happen and
you guys are the perfect generation and
the perfect people
to carry us through this in the long run
and i'm so proud of you
for that generation now tim next year
is your 25th wedding anniversary
next year yes i didn't want to scare you
yeah no next year
yeah your diamond anniversary it's a big
deal are you do you have plans in place
i'm not yet but i got to come up with
something don't i got to have a good
plan
you do you know i got to figure
something really good out
i'm pretty good at that i'm usually
usually for our 10th anniversary i built
a
at our farm i built a knights of arabia
tent with a bed and a movie screen
and a dinner table and fires
bonfires all outside of it so we spent
the night up in the knights of arabia
ten watched foreign film
so that was my you need to talk to my
husband yeah figure that out
i love that and you tease the i yeah go
ahead
i'll come up with something good yeah
and
you teased the whole damn short do video
on your instagram
uh what is that video and is what how
did faith react to the video
she loved it you know what it was oddly
enough
a fan had put that video together and i
saw it
and i thought it was so special and so
cool that i wanted to just
add a little bit of that of damn sure do
to it just to see how it would turn out
and it worked out perfectly so i i owe
that all to a fan who just put a great
video it's amazing
now talking about your you know your
your journey 27 years
this is your 16th studio album there's
always when you create new music and
content there's always that one person
or maybe there's a bunch of people
whose opinion matters the most to you
who's that person to you
well my wife first i want her to hear it
and i want to get her opinion and we
don't always agree
you know and stuff i mean yeah different
musical taste
but i have a handful of people that are
are
in the industry and people that are not
in the industry and that
buddy of mine i went to college with you
know just a few people that
are don't really even listen to music
that much but there's a handful of
people that
that is that are my study group that i i
play music for just to get their
reaction to it and
most the time they're pretty dead on
sometimes yeah
sometimes i miss too
what do you miss the most about being on
tour i just miss the energy you know
that that time you know i guess growing
up being an athlete
and um you know the time before the game
starts the time in the locker room or
the time of the dugout before the game
starts there's
this tremendous energy and this this
anticipation
that you get and i really miss that
before you hit the stage when the lights
go out
and you hear the the music that's
getting ready that cause you're on the
stage and the crowd screaming
and lighters going off and and you
that anticipation of going out with your
your best friends who are my band
and uh who are the best musicians in the
world so i get to stand up there
and play this great music with these
great players and have all these lights
and lasers and
and 30 000 people who are having a great
time i mean there there's just there's
just no way to quite replace that
i guess you could do it in your backyard
and see what happens and maybe yeah
that's your
my kids were here to say dad shut up
you know tim i have to tell you one of
my favorite shows was friday night
lights
it's been years and years would you ever
consider rebooting that show
i don't know nobody's ever asked about
that again i think
i think there needs to be a sequel to it
that would be a good good idea
we need to put that out there no pete
berg needs to he needs to think about
that for sure
you know from all this experience that
you've had you're releasing an album out
of time life is bringing that joy
what was the priority to you before all
of this happened
is not a priority anymore
oh gosh um that's a tough one
um because i only have a few priorities
anyway what are those
eat sleep where's my wife
no um i i guess just to make
make sure to just be in contact with
your kids more
i mean that's really the main thing is
just really
contact each other more and tell each
other you love them more
and those kind of things some some of
the things you take for granted because
you think
we'll always all be here and uh you know
life will always be the same and we'll
just roll along and have a great time
but it's not like that and
so there are times when when uh they
need to know
and you need to know that that
foundation's there
you